we introduced the whole idea of of
calculus and differentiating what's this
idea with a gradient function right we
took awhile to do that we would you join
because of apples and moons and that
kind of thing then we started to get
down to brass tacks with the whole idea
of different unit right we've sort of
developed two if you like to call them
our rules for differentiating we look
the things that you can differentiate
which are like polynomials things the
powers on them right or you can start a
number at the front door like type of
thing okay we look at those we looked at
what happened when you took a function
like this I've got x squared minus 1
over there and then you raise that to a
power so it's like this balance steroids
okay and we called this we have it two
days we call the chain rule or function
of a function rule all right so this is
great these will help us to deal with
these kinds of functions but there are
lots more kinds of functions and so we
introduce lots of all kinds of rules to
deal with them in a quick way rather
than always going back to first
principles which is tremendously
inefficient very time-consuming ok so
that's my sort of preamble for we're
going to learn this show that you learn
the quotient rule as well and why are we
learning all these rules it's a pain
trying to remember all of them the
reason why we learn them is because it's
quicker than going back to first
principles and always doing that ok so
thank you well we're gonna start with an
example that we could do without product
rule actually so that I can demonstrate
why we need plug okay so here's a
function how do you differentiate it if
I was saying work out dy on DX okay or
another kind of a notation that I
introduced in that first lesson was why
- just shorthand for a different shape
um what would you do with this okay now
I know we can expand it out and treat it
look normal
okay but for now I just want to imagine
it well it's a product of two other
functions right so would it be
unreasonable to think
if you've got the function here let's
call this part F okay
actually I'm not calling you instead
because that's what we really fall in
line up got a function now I'm going to
call you
I've got another function here that I
multiply my I'm called we're gonna call
it be okay if I define y - and I've got
u times V it wouldn't be unusual to
think can I take you - and V - right
differentiate each one and they've
multiplied them right so I'm saying
maybe the derivative of a product would
be the product of the derivatives okay
let's try this let's see what happens
let's consider if I'll put in red let's
consider what was if y dash is equal to
u - times V - okay I'm gonna
differentiate each one what happened
what's the duty of an x squared just 2x
yeah we're gonna power down reduce the
power by 1 and the derivative of x
squared minus 1 is also the same right
because that minus 1 offer me any
different share and it just disappears
okay somewhere is on here is 4x squared
4x squared now if we didn't know any
better we'd say well it seems the chin
right why not okay but you guys know
you've probably already sort of doing
the numbers this is a little suspicious
for starters the degree of this right
the degree of this polynomial is what's
the degree it's for when we
differentiate things with powers right
we expect them to go down by one so if
the degree is 4 we would expect the
derivative to have a degree of 3 but are
there number two what's going on okay
so sure enough let's expand it first and
then differentiate with the rules we
already know
and huh this because it's wrong and I'll
let's expand it out okay so I'm gonna
first consider Y as X to the 4 minus x
squared I'm happy with that it's just an
expansion so now what I take to you on
the X Y - I'll just do each one each
time and you get 4 X cubed minus 2x ok
and what you can do is you can you can
graph this it's quite easy to graph and
you can verify this is the pattern that
the gradient function follows it's not
just for expand this way too simple okay
so therefore when you're dealing with
products you can't just simply
differentiate each one and then multiply
them together we need to introduce a way
or well how would you come up with this
without expanding like here it's easy to
expand but what if it was a disaster to
expand what if it was something like X
to the 4 and x squared minus 1 to the
7th okay so there's a chain will be
there I don't want to expand this is
what a pain okay so what can I do with
it now